a punitive amount of logos movie follows
James Cameron's footsteps and goes with
the papyrus font which guarantees I will
pay even less attention than normal to
the opening credits frequent Neil LaBute
actor Aaron Eckhart makes a cameo
appearance in this movie but has enacted
in another LaBute project since I'm
gonna form a huge correlation causation
opinion here and just assume the Wicker
Man was that toxic no one will be seated
during the exciting Nicolas Cage grabs a
doll off the road as he speeds past its
scene where the hell did this truck come
from we see officer Nicholas Cage
walking calmly to the side of the street
where that truck was surely visible but
it comes crashing through like it was
conceived by the heart of gold's
infinite improbability drive
I'll admit this crash looks horrific but
sudden fire emergency this opening scene
was pretty much pointless right does it
have to do with I'll keep watching I
guess I heard about your commendation
for fucking what there was a wreck and
nobody survived or even existed as we're
about to find out but this guy's getting
a commendation so they still never found
the bodies from that car right why the
movies do this skip over a whole bunch
of interesting stuff to go straight to
the reclusive depressed detective who
just needs a little time off we hear
about nobodies in the car but we don't
make any discoveries that make us active
viewers I didn't want to hurt you any
more than I did
now I must and then the plot is
propelled through letter narration
reading I'm actually longing for a huge
mysterious truck to just ram into
Edwards house right now it wouldn't make
sense but it would be awesome his modern
wife wrote him a letter but did so with
her great great grandmother's
handwriting for some reason she has been
missing for two weeks now you might
notice she looks exactly like the girl
you let die in the car crash earlier the
plot thickens didn't even know you had a
plot this character is way too aware of
this movie shortcomings summers oh I'm
glad
Edward bothered visiting this friend
character slash stick figure because he
weaves a rich tapestry these must be his
stop seeing horrific visions pills mom
Eden on blond people go to heaven of
course not sweetie now pose for the
stock photo
mr. grant hair is twin brother Ulysses I
didn't want to take you there because I
didn't want to lose my business with
summersisle but I guess 150 bucks is
enough to completely reverse my position
and you know that officer from
California are the woman's supposed to
represent bees here like they have a
hive mind or something does this woman
know who he is already and why doesn't
he ask her how she knows that
édouard drinks one glass of island mead
and suddenly feels the need to disrupt
this entire bar and announce why he's
here like some sort of hard-ass like the
whole island is definitely guilty I'm
not entirely sure I'm gonna disagree
with his fate in this movie be murdered
this will become important later there's
a place out beyond the point meet me
there in an hour
this girl's note couldn't be more vague
of a tribe there's a spot nearby that
one thing meet me there in a while cold
by the way this actress filled a weird
actor stereotype in the mid 2000s where
she always played in someone's daughter
is missing movies like flightplan
actually I think it's just two movies
but that still works as a sin or
something I need to ask you some
questions
willow writes a note tells Edward to
come out to the secret place and he
learns absolutely nothing ah this cop
travels with EpiPens is that lazy
character information or haphazard plot
development does it matter yes all the
Wicker man's return roll credits the
director said carry a whole basket full
of apples and eat one of them it'll make
you look like even more of an asshole
did some of them pack my bag because I'm
missing some tapes people who live here
decide to steal Edward self-help tapes
for some dumbass reason Edward flashes
back to an entirely meaningless moment
on the boat where he realized that
Blonde Ambition over here wasn't the
girl who died in the crash the beginning
of the movie or was the missing girl he
was looking for this is a flashback of a
dream of something that happened to an
entirely different girl wholly this
movie in this part of the flashback
Edward turns his head and suddenly the
people in the car are gone I wonder if
he'll also remember putting crash-test
dummies in the car before he went to get
the doll because that would be
certifiably insane
these are some ridiculously well lit
woods for one o'clock in the morning on
it essentially Amish Island
Ron ah the audience sees the Bugaboo run
by in the dark while the main character
only hears it cliche it's a jump-scare
staple because nothing is happening it's
almost guaranteed he falls through the
floor and Edward decided not to look any
further that night and just went to bed
dreaming of trucks crashing into girls
no self-respecting restaurant would put
a honey bear this empty on a table where
actual customers are going to sit fill
that up waiter and of course he wants
some honey in his team so we get the
comically overblown scene of him waiting
for the tiny amount of honey to run down
the container walls our crop was cursed
last year believing in curses and
furthermore believing in crop based
curses also leelee sobieski is playing
the same expositional role here she
played an eyes wide shut
only with close-up he only just now
notices this creepy wall of similar
pictures whoever broke this frame is
doing way more work than should be
necessary to create intrigue and
keep this asshole on the island no I
mean tomorrow what's happening you here
then I told you you did the guy we saw
yelling in a bar a few minutes ago about
a missing girl sure doesn't like asking
follow-up questions when people are
being mysterious assholes
okay so this movie is a real-life
version of the village only without the
creepy monster red herring gotcha
Ballack symbol phallic symbol well
little girls saying this in any context
is not okay so I'm going to add 50 sins
just to cover myself legally yeah Edward
maelys from California malice as in male
if you didn't get it also they used that
mal which means bad in Sanskrit or
whatever language that is just to
confuse the whole movie with more
subtlety edward erases this chalkboard
without permission also he can write the
missing girls really simple name on it
she existed we would know of her and
another weird thing somebody says is
that edward does not follow up on if she
existed the photography clearly proved
she did if she existed is what a person
in a cult of man-hating women would say
whose desk is this instead of saying
it's a spare the teacher looks away
guiltily so that both Nic Cage and the
audience know Rowan was here at one
point
that's a burdened desk right there he
trapped a little bird inside see how
long he can stand it
unlike most birds it somehow managed to
stay quiet and not kill itself trying to
get out so it could be a jump-scare dick
do you have sister Summer Isles
Authority no this guy doesn't even do
the most basic of detective work
everyone's been mentioning this sister
summersisle and edward just plain ain't
interested in finding out who she is or
talking to her and maybe she's got some
answers who knows you told me another on
I'll rescue myself that is a promise
Miss Rose sister Rose of course another
plant Rose this Kate performance what's
funny is this is a former motorcycle cop
who takes a lot of drugs has never made
detective and his way out of his
jurisdiction asking questions in a place
where detectives are never seen and
where the people have an obi-wan way of
looking at things a certain infuriating
point of view I've got an idea
maybe this movie is a word of genius but
it's nearly impossible to enjoy on
anything but it can't be level because
the main character never acts like a
human being I told you that if Rowan
Woodward existed we would know of her
but am I going to explain this point of
view hell no you got a guess what we
mean mother she's dead or she isn't we
never use that word here no that'd be
too quixotic
it really really isn't but if you look
at this movie in the way I'm currently
looking at it this is a drug down
motorcycle cop who thinks he's getting a
good zinger in which sister Rose simply
lets umbrella SHhhh how'd she die she'll
burn to death how in the world did these
people become such expert practical
jokers and the way they speak was camp
a simple misstep right they're all
putting with them on a nuclear level but
it's almost improvised ma using the same
actress and different roles to imply
incest cliche and now I feel dirty just
having said that hey didn't I just speak
with you miss rows of sister Rose no you
didn't and again no need to follow that
up not even are you her twin sister this
guy takes some amazing drugs but they
put it there I didn't who's that
exactly willow uses the pronoun game
here so that edward has to ask who they
means but you know what I'm beginning to
wonder if this woman even exists she
apparently lives on this island in this
commune but hasn't given Edward dick so
far as information is concerned not that
he's gonna ask the right questions
anyway I don't know whoever's however is
doing this trick try trying to meet well
thanks you know it's not a mystery just
because the movie gives me one tiny fact
at a time
it's a mystery because I get a
mysterious and unknown feeling which you
cannot recreate with dialogue fragments
and a walk off that aint creepy it's
just annoying sister Sam Rizal has never
been very fond of my wild ways yeah that
name keeps coming up almost as though
it's important um lost character tells
everyone in the audience exactly what
they're feeling hm
groans father this information could
easily have been given earlier but I
will not be suspicious of it at all so
there's where your last saw wrong it
only took three days but Edward finally
asks this question this chick looks like
22 tops I'm not judging age ain't
nothing but a number but he's got to be
like three times her age no and they
have a school-aged daughter too child
draws disturbing in the horror movie
cliche and Wow thank God she used her
desk instead of paper Rowling
it's the airplane delivery guy but
damned if I know how this cult of
man-eaters managed to kill the guy stuck
him down onto the dock and leave the
area before Edward ran down here the
unreliable main characters POV continues
to save due to the audience
gah it's a dream fake out within a dream
fake out there are no words to describe
the few feelings i currently have for
this movie taking pills without water or
other beverage on creepy island this cop
decides to remove his gun an ID before
swimming over to a water plane I guess
the gun makes sense water and all but
your badge they also managed to destroy
the pilots radio in the amount of time
it took Edward to run down here
Edward continues to believe this means
something to these people also he
decided to go to someone else first
rather than the freaking queen bee of
this island again thanks is that all
you're going to ask about getting a
duplicate picture and that's it you have
nothing else on your mind at all any
asshole could easily see Edward here but
I'm pretty sure he thinks this is a
great hiding place if it's straight
metal it will definitely open any door
having seen the skills Edward has
displayed so far in this movie it's a
miracle this works why did you tell me
wrong was a part of all this ah the
rituals I I don't know movie attempts
and succeeds in making you unreasonably
angry at the words I don't know look I'm
trying to trust you here but every time
I turn my head there's something it
doesn't make any sense
movie speaks the audience members
concerns for them yes there's definitely
time for this what the hell is this
scene this is just more proof that
Edward is a failure and everything he
does why did he even bother helping
didn't he just being offer to help low
the Long's
and then the long spell after he helped
and now he's leaving they were better
off before he ever showed up dick no
vows or afters eat him in this scene
this field of beekeeping stuff is set up
in the same hexagonal shape as behind in
some movies that'd be worth us in
removal force energy in this movie it's
worth 10 sins added for pounding me over
the head Jesus Christ this is a pretty
open field how does he keep running
edition falling down listen if he's
allergic to bee stings he's dead already
if not then this is a big waste of time
so what's it gonna be movie this guy
only dreams about trucks hitting little
girls this is the home of sister
summersisle Jesus finally his right kid
the adrenaline shot oh no so I treated
the danger in the old way leeches
is it Li just she's been expecting you
well duh
he's been snooping around this island
for like days now the women of this
island stole his fucking self-help tapes
but not his gun guy a was afraid of bees
doesn't seem all that concerned about
hundreds of bees swarming the area to
the Great Mother Goddess who rules this
island well well I would have guessed
that was you and I'm surprised to learn
it's not you
this is still some vague ass bowls my
Celtic ancestors all the way back
rebelled against the suppression of the
feminine all the clues you've seen so
far point to you needing to get the
Kaaba silent but you're a serial ignore
do I have permission to open the grave
of Rowan Woodward you didn't but what
I'm wondering about is why is it super
day outside when she grants him
permission but he waits until scary last
night to do this Ron - every little
sound have to be Rowan Ron calling out
to daughter who even if she isn't in her
own grave is probably still dead
since we know Rowan isn't dead did they
know he'd go this far to find a sweater
that was obviously planted for him to
find legitimately waiting for Danny
DeVito's penguin to show up any minute
this guy actually thinks the crying he
heard a minute ago which was super close
to him would now be this far away from
him luckily this water is lit from
within but I guess algae I'm going
without Oh
seconds after seeing someone sabotage
this exit this idiot calls for help as
though anyone but those who dem could
currently be in earshot um dark clouds
overtaking current light source is one
of the oldest metaphorical tricks in the
book I oh I don't even know why he
bothers to flashback when these things
are already filled with misinformation
and reconstructed untruths
but the sniffing the possibly dead
daughter sweater days after her capture
and at least 24 hours after its
submersion into that prison pit pool
that's dub is hers
how they at this point I'm actually with
Nicolas Cage on this this has got to be
the most frustrating investigation ever
even though he's bad at it how did you
burn how did you burn how to get burn
don't know I mean out of context the
performance is super crazy I mean it is
kind of crazy but goddamn nobody knows
or tells us guys the entire movie
summers all summers Isle summers Isle is
a comically stupid name and we're about
to hear it about 435 times in this scene
alone we know Edward isn't elucidating
this because the girl doesn't get hit by
truck wait did they know he was coming
to the house so they could set up this
practical joke long after arriving here
this cop finally decides to do a house
by house search to find out where on
creepy island this girl is being hit
discount Deadpool from x-men origins
Wolverine did you say to that business
at the Harbor the business that took
place three days ago sure you can't
watch this scene without laughing
especially since the movie shows Edward
walking towards her for 16 full seconds
before he unleashes this punch she
doesn't really deserve it especially
since he has very little proof of
anything
anyone's actually done in this movie but
damn if you don't feel like a million
bucks when he does it anyway oh yeah and
the cherries on top but it is violence
towards women so we're gonna have to add
50 more sins for that you can see the
bind we're in oh goddess of the fields
well if any of this that happened
earlier in the film the film would be a
lot shorter I guess but as a viewer I
still feel kind of jerked around on this
one Jesus I'll fuckin biggest creepy
Island anyway I thought it was small and
yes let's follow the little girl young
enough to be following her imaginary
friends directions right now somehow
this little girl gets a giant lead on
Edward by the time we find out she's
just led him into a trap so this whole
movie was a giant ruse to get him to the
island so they could sacrifice it but
the way they did it was so freakin
stupid the letter he got didn't even
State the daughter was his and left it
completely up to chance that he would go
through all this bull to save this girl
did they set up the car crash at the
beginning of the movie so he'd feel like
he needed to save someone and also if
they did this in order to get him here
why did they even bother killing the
airplane delivery guy didn't he do
exactly what was needed to make this
plan work for fuck's sake we
orchestrated all of this with the
greatest care everything that's happened
even that small moment when you weren't
looking and I smelled the sweater like
it was important to me you can't put on
a good ruse unless you do it at all
times
even when you think no one's looking
this is a story whose chapters were
carefully written goddammit there's no
way the cop and the two people who were
in the car crash managed to be part of
this plot at all who hit them with the
truck how did they get out of the car
before it got hit without Edward seeing
that why did this cop decide to work for
the police force for years just so she
could deliver a letter to Edward also
this is a plan that requires a hundred
things to go right in order to work but
it's masterful know by the way Edward
witness this nonsense earlier in the
movie and the sacrifice was supposed to
take place the day of tomorrow which is
never explained but wasn't he here like
a week after that
as always whenever someone takes bullets
out of a gun they've been secretly
holding them the entire time for a
dramatic reveal also a window that she
managed to do that peek out they
impotent accusations killing me won't
bring back your goddamn money
oh yeah that's another thing all this is
to keep up that sweet sweet honey
harvest that no doubt brings in an up
doe and sustains the entire community
the bringing back the honey ritual of
killing this dude first requires the
public breaking of his knees because of
course seriously if you broke both my
knees while I was subdued and in custody
I'd probably die of sorrow or at least
the feeling of uselessness what what is
that what is that
that man you are the most annoying
person I've ever seen getting tortured
in a movie oh not the Bears not the bees
and oh yeah forgot to mention this is
the story of a man who was allergic to
bees who needs to find a missing girl
missing girl just happens to be on an
island full of bees poetry sure okay but
now they're also in your mouth after all
that screaming
these CGI bees are almost as bad as a
CGI birds and Birdemic
did they open this blanket just so that
he could see where they were taking him
God and his society forces the daughter
of the accused to light the fuse to his
or her death
ruthless Nicolas Cage how did she get
here in time after getting knocked the
fuck out also why did she ask Edward to
take her with him when he left the
island is that just more bull to make
him feel like the island was evil there
was no point in that no seriously that's
the end I know right look this movie is
also so they somehow tricked him into
King this one girl and pregnant in her
with this other girl who they then
pretended was missing also they could
stab this guy with a thousand bees and
burn him to death do I have that right
for Jayram own state why
a powerful tidal wave in Kuala Lumpur
has killed 120 people hate you our hey
no it was that Burpee bird Oh
story goes that he'll be normal during
the day but at night in the presence of
evil the writer takes over your madam
I've been shown in the files of the War
Department a statement the adjutant
general of Massachusetts that you are
the mother of five sons of died
gloriously on the field of battle
everywhere
yonder here they're ripping like what do
you see we cut the chitchat a hole the
legend writ the stain effected the key
in silence undetected I called mr. Fox
when your condition worsened after the
first day I analyzed your blood
isolating the receptor compounds and the
protein based cast I can't tell what she
sees in you
what kind of rough potential Thanks
I guess not too bright though